au même moment une une vidéo suscite une
vive polémique celle semblant montrer
selon Kiev un soldat russe décapant au
couteau un prisonnier ukrainien Loni se
dit aujourd'hui horrifié l'Union
européenne demandera des comptes à tous
les auteurs et complices de crime de
guerre à déclaré tout à l'heure une
porte-parole du chef de la diplomatie
européenne le Kremlin a également réagi
de son côté et d'y vouloir vérifier
l'authenticité de ces images horribles
je cite on va retrouver tout de suite
pour tenter d'y voir un peu plus clair
sur cette nouvelle affaire gulliverkra
qui est de notre correspondre à qui est
bonjour Gulliver rappelons que le
document dont il est question on a pour
le moment pas été authentifié que
sait-on pour le moment de cette affaire
alors c'est une vidéo qui a apparemment
été publié sur un groupe télégram privé
en Russie visiblement un groupe de
nationalistes russes puis fuité par
d'autres vers d'autres
chats sur telegram chaîne sur télégram
qui sont accessibles aux grands publics
d'après ce que j'ai vu certains russes
l'ont même condamné en ligne sur ces
réseaux sociaux mais bien sûr c'est un
Ukraine d'abord que cela a suscité le
plus grand tollé c'est une vidéo qui ne
date pas d'hier selon ce qu'on voit de
la végétation dans la vidéo elle aurait
probablement été filmé en été mais il
est assez clair quand on regarde la
vidéo ce qui se passe malheureusement ce
n'est pas du tout facile à regarder et
c'est justement cela que vous le dire
the lensky le président ukrainien a dit
il a rapidement publié une déclaration
vidéo lui-même ou littéralement il
réclame une la réaction internationale
en disant que les leaders du monde ne
peuvent pas rester ici silencieux sur
ces atrocités des réactions
internationales ont commencé à bien sûr
à arriver il y a eu aussi un commentaire
du ministre des Affaires étrangères
Ukrainiens Dimitri bas qui lui dit que
il était absurde que la Russie soit en
ce moment en train de présider le
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
alors que selon les modes de métro
couliba la Russie est pire que la
soi-disant le soi-disant est état
islamique avec ses géants d'action dans
les commentaires que j'ai vu aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux
Ukrainiens à part justement seulement
les expressions d'horreur il y a eu
aussi certaines personnes qui je pense
aussi pour pour
justifier pour alimenter l'argument
comme quoi la vidéo est probablement
vrai il raconte des témoignages qu'ils
ont reçu des personnes ayant été en
captivité chez les Russes qui racontent
que des forces russes ou des forces
soutenues par la
dans le dans le basse en Ukraine on
aurait commis des atrocités pareilles et
même pas seulement en 2022 mais aussi en
2014 contre la guerre dans le Dondas a
commencé merci beaucoup gonna en direct
de Kiev pour France 24